Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shadow be repeated award
click the link and donate what you can
there's a reason being I talk about this
is because I want to deal with the
problem at its root I don't want to go
to the leaves I want to go to the root
of the tree so I believe that when you
don't have God in your life when there
is no objective morality what happens is
society starts breaking down and I tie
that back to not having God in your life
so that's that's my argument you might
disagree with it so I say for example so
so the reason I say is is this because
at the end of the day when it comes to
inconsistencies we have the lgbqt
community who is saying that we are born
in this way but when a person comes and
says I won't have an insidial
relationship they are shunned and I say
well hold on a second be consistent with
your liberal worldview if a man and his
daughter or a brother and a sister who
are 16 are going to use if there's kids
okay okay
do you think that do you think that's
fine that a a a a father a father has
intimacy with her with his 18 year old
daughter One Second One Second One
Second One Second
this is why you need God let me tell you
why the moment
when I mentioned a father and a 18 year
old grown adult woman
his biological daughter who's 18 years
old legally is correct both of your
faces change and he said that is
irrational can you tell me how this is
what I'm saying when you don't have what
God there's inconsistencies how 18 year
old girl 18 year old girl
okay but make the point once I've made I
want to finish my point yeah even having
the UK a father and daughter I had
intimacy yes not only that we actually
have a child but together let's say they
use condoms yeah please tell me on your
world view how is that wrong and why
doesn't the lgbtqt community add I for
incest at the end I want to know why
because there's inconsistency to me it's
because it's still
it's still well
in that case the
400 she's an
adults
she's an adult
so why is why is it one second you can
you can have a 35 year old man
manipulate a 16 year old girl so but the
law says is she 16 yes she has a right
to sex now I'm saying why when this is a
father-daughter it can be a mother son
it can be a brother sister why is that
wrong
why why just why give a second I'll ask
you why you think it's similar to being
gay simple being gay I'm going about my
life in society I'm a law of my
assistant I go and meet somebody who's
the same gender as me I have a nice
relationship with them and I have sex
with them yeah how is that the same okay
can I explain why well he asked me a
question you said two men who are
homosexual who meet each other two women
for that matter no problem they have
they have intimacy yeah what is wrong
with that I see let's go with your world
view nothing wrong with it why is it
wrong for an adult man and his adult
daughter or an adult woman and her adult
son or two siblings who are both adults
going about their life wasn't it it's
good
why is it bad you think it's good no I'm
saying why is it bad for your worldview
why do you think it's good no I believe
it's wrong but why is it wrong but
because
God tells me but why why did God say
okay very very simple good so I believe
this is wrong because we have an
objective morality which ties to God you
guys have a subjective morality what
does God say though that says it's in
situation is not permissible why then
why surely God says it's not because he
said something yeah
for example for example for example
one second but what I'm saying is we
have objective morality you guys are
subjective
morality this is what I'm saying before
we've inherited living in the west yes
exactly yeah so now tell me why is it
wrong for ancestral relationship you
said what's the there's a difference
there's two reasons they say we're born
like that I love my daughter my daughter
loves me well I love my sisters my
sister loves me why are you guys against
her you are now going against the
liberal paradigms there's no children
there's no children if they had a child
no children because they're very unwell
no children and also it's really like no
kids no very disturbing can a man and a
man have a child
I'm
not the red sister we're not even
decided because the two of them to adopt
each other I don't know if I would see
anything wrong with that thank you now
what I'm saying is then why okay so are
you Pro incest now no that's not incest
is having sex with your relationship
yeah brother and sister having sex you
said if they adopted a child together
I said if they weren't having sex oh no
no no no that's weird okay you said it's
weird homosexuality was weird 50 years
ago and it wasn't it homosexuality it
was
I know I know that
acceptable business right in in Nazi
Germany killing the Jews were acceptable
it doesn't make it right it's like when
you bring up the Nazis you've lost the
arguments
no I'm just saying in those times it was
okay to kill a Jew I'm not saying this
thing I'm saying the expected
that's the point where we're gonna see
now it's more like the Nazi Germany
period of time majority of society
why are you rejecting are you rejecting
themselves in 50 years time it will be
like the way we look back on so so
you're saying that should we accept
ancestral relationships mate can we just
talk about something else because
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry with
incest because they're both different uh
Josh come on are you questioning
somebody's love
if a brother and sister love each other
how could you question is
take a deep breath actually hang out and
be friends with some homosexual people I
know I know three people I know people
who are homosexuals
no no you need to you need to you need
to like you're going against large are
you against love no no you're being Love
Is Love Josh antagonistic ow come on
Love Is Love then why can't brother and
sister be loving love because that's
just wrong it's like okay
physical basis
that's why we need God
haven't got God and neither
less likely
good so what we're saying is can a 30
year old homosexual man coerce a 16 year
old homosexual boy yes so my point is
the following
I know I know
I'm not a good friend who was going out
with the 16
th
I still might be like oh that's a little
bit unusual that's my point the only
thing I'm trying to make here I don't
know you were saying that gay people are
the same as people which is fundamental
I love his love and also incredibly
offensive
it is very incredibly it is
you are against ancestral relationship
with two people who love each other I
can say you are now in your liberal
world view right if you want to advocate
for incest that's your you can do that
is an interesting debate that this man
is love no love for more insects so you
guys if there's two people who want to
have an essential relationship you call
you're calling them weird abnormal
I'm sorry that I am coming down too
harsh on incest you I'm sorry I
apologize you go for it you've argued
them quotes about success yeah that's
you know good for you I don't really
know if we have anymore
I don't know if you can go back when
homosexuality were accepted
anyone so they were using the harm
principle of course right now you have
certain groups me and Ali are not
advocating for instance you've got
certain groups I'm trying to show the
double standards I'm showing that you
guys should be promoting that yeah no no
no you're not understanding what we're
doing it's okay
it's very surface but guys can I explain
it
on what basis there's no harm on what
Beast my point is this homosexuality no
harm to adults good in sexual
relationship to adults no harm bad
that's my
points
I told you there's no kids
thank you of using the homosexual
argument thank you to Supreme Court yes
and they say and the law is not looking
at us
they're just trying to have a nice life
what if they called gays weird it was
the ancestral ones all the time
but you're not looking at it with a lot
of delicacy you're being very very blunt
very basic in your assessment of the
world I would say maybe I'm very
unimpressed by your assessment of this
debate
no all we're saying is the insist
community in the homosexual Community
have the same guideline and same basis
and they have the same argument yet the
law looks differently that's my point
we're consistent in our argument and we
both reject incest and almost
successive and unpleasant to a large
group of people
trying to make them live in a certain
way you're trying to control the way
they live their lives having
relationships with people they don't
know suicide because they can't be
homosexual do you know how much like
impression homosexual people feel living
into Society literally people either or
they don't have sex their whole life and
they live their whole life alone and
that's a really unpleasant thing for gay
people to experience and you don't want
these people to have a little bit of
happiness in their life and then there's
all these children and these people into
this community
okay one second one second guys one
second if a brother and sister said if
you don't allow us to have intimacy and
we love each other we'll commit suicide
would you defend their rights to believe
that right would you defend the right to
a brother and sister to have intimacy
Obama please
Josh if a brother and sister says
they go to the Supreme Court and say we
love each other we want to marry each
other if you don't allow us we'll commit
suicide would you guys be standing
outside and saying we're defending
sexual rights this is the trolley
problem this is the trolley okay
I don't know
maybe because if it's just gonna be the
two of you go go away
look he calls them weird but when we say
when we say the same homosexuality look
when we're against homosexuality weren't
bad when he's in a decision relationship
they're bad I don't understand it's
inconsistencies that's all I'm saying
it's highly consistent I'll let the
viewers decide but what I'm saying is
look I'm sorry
don't be careful
owns two atheists because I don't feel
like you have owners
Advocate foreign
dropped
I literally did again
now if if a man
one second bro one second if a man who's
35 years old he says the legal age the
legal age in America is 14 years old he
travels to America and he finds a boy or
a girl and he says I am
and the 14 year old girl or boy says I
legally I'm allowed and they say this is
love do you accept that love no no
incest no pedophilia no homosexuality
yes I think consistency that's what I'm
saying
two points one two consenting adults
which is completely not the case in the
other instance
[Music]
in America the legal age is 14. yeah
and that's weird
but that's your subject
s because we as religious people will
say no to that we'll say nothing says
homosexuality that's my point but you
know why it's 14. right because of
religion because we want to say honestly
because of America because yeah America
100 America is redeem South it's in
Georgia a very religious State and it's
because people have a really a tradition
of marrying young because they feel like
they have to marry young because they
can't have sex before marriage that's a
good thing no but that's why you get to
people getting married at 14.
that's legally allowed in America well
it's 14 15 yards I mean I mean which one
is better a 16 year old girl who goes
and sleeps around or gets married guess
my other point is about science and
health and genetic diversity which is
not an issue with gay people but it is
an issue with people they have a right
to have sexual disease as well like they
do like a thing
well they do that there's a lot of
sexually transmitted disease amongst men
like for example because it's because if
you think about it if there's kids
please leave the building if you think
about it a man is inserting his penis
into another man's rectum where we
heterosexual relationships
it's true relationship with a man and a
woman he's saying this is it's wrong
that's what I'm saying it's not wrong
it's not wrong okay I'm sorry sorry
I'm sorry
notice what the points we've made we've
made two strong arguments sorry to
support our side of the argument which
is and neither of you you said consent I
said is it coercion Collision that's all
commercial your child Peter fitted bad
adult version of child and I'm saying
that genetic a lack of genetics
valid but I'm saying two concentric
adults having sex with each other is
completely fine
and that is the end of it I believe I
believe it's a good argument I believe
it's a good argument however for those
for those who are clapping a yeah for
those who are clapping a a brother and a
sister one second one second coercion
and genetics let's deal with it
incestral relationship a brother and a
sister both adults both using condoms
why is that wrong for the ones that are
clapping in the back are they
thank you very much the point is very
clear double standards of hip is
hypocrisy look coercion and genetics the
valid point I accept it let's talk it
let's take it to a brother and sister
both adults having sex and uh please
kids if we have kids away from here
please yes they have an intimacy you
can't argue
the point I'm saying is this when you
don't have a legislation from look from
God almighty this is the problem you
face because you don't have an objective
morality we have the Sharia Allah says
eight we follow a Allah says b with a
low B but to their world view they say
except homosexuality we say okay why
there's no coercion genetically no
disorder okay let's use the same
argument with a brother and a sister 18
18 they have intimacy and they use
protection what do they say that's wrong
one rule for here one rule for that this
is the problem we're showing and you saw
very clearly they run away the LGB cutie
Community they do not accept incision
relationship because it's bad but
homosexuality it's good there you go and
you know how many people are afraid to
speak about this they lose their jobs
they lack the Mafia the LGBT community
is like a mafia if I was working if I
was working in Tesco or next I would
have lost my job tomorrow my manager
will be calling yesterday
Ali did you have a discussion about here
I just gave my ideas you're fired
this is the oppression this is what
we're talking about alhamdulillah you
can make your own argument you heard the
argument and we address them that's all
I need to say alhamdulillah we have
Islam
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you and the shall
be replaced click the link and donate
what you can